bienvenue dans reporter sur france 24
nouvel épisode aujourd'hui de notre
série sur les frontières du monde ces
points chauds de la géopolitique et nous
partons sur le fleuve oyapock en
amazonie qui marque la frontière entre
le brésil et la guyane française 700 km
de rives à surveiller théâtre de trafics
en tous genres d'immigration illégale et
d'orpaillage clandestin une frontière
officiellement fermée à cause de la
pandémie mais une frontière quasi
impossible à contrôler cet art portage
de fanny le ter et laura damase avec
séverine bardon et olivier mars
[Musique]
une activité inhabituelle agite le cours
de l'oyapock
elle en train de passer notre côté nous
approcher ou
au coeur de la forêt amazonienne le
fleuve matérialise une partie des 700 km
de frontière entre la guyane et le
brésil
là on va pas débarquer
tous les jours près de 3000 pirogue
effectué la traversée entre les deux
rives pour lutter contre les passages
clandestins et les trafics qui gangrène
la région
la france et le brésil test d'une
opération fluvial conjointe
bonjour bonjour monsieur le sous-préfet
vous allez bien ça va bonjour bonjour
comment se passe cette opération russe
le brésil a mobilisé plus d'une
vingtaine d'hommes lourdement armés
côté français seuls trois embarcations
ont pris part à l'opération
le sous préfet de guyane venu en
observateur dresse un bilan lucide de la
situation
est extrêmement dissuasif
l'armement brésilien
monsieur pour m
de quoi tenir cette frontière tout seul
[Musique]
si le fleuve des limites aujourd'hui les
territoires guyanaise et brésiliens il a
longtemps servi de trait d'union entre
les populations indigènes de part et
d'autre de ces rives
orly loyo et l'adjoint du chef coutumier
d'espérance 2 un village lui yann et qui
abrite une soixantaine de familles de
l'ethnie pas licour
grand mère tu as bien
dans cette région des confins de la
france plus de la moitié de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
comme la plupart de ses voisins la maire
d'orly a perdu son travail suite à la
pandémie pendant des mois elle a vécu de
l'aide alimentaire fournie par l'état
français mais ces réserves se sont
épuisés
il ne reste plus que de la farine
vos potos le reste est terminée
la vessie voci il faut en racheter ça
coûte 5 euros pour un petit paquet de
lessive c'est vraiment très cher et
c'est douloureux pour moi de voir que ma
mère ne peut pas acheter de quoi
subvenir aux besoins de notre famille
face à cette précarité grandissante les
familles comme celle d'orly s'organise
avec les moyens du bord
qu'est-ce qu'il faut acheter du poulet
côté brésilien les produits de première
nécessité sont cinq fois moins cher
qu'en guyane pour quelques paquets de
riz de café et de sucre orly et sa mère
vont prendre le risque de traverser la
frontière fermée à cause du coc vie
les populations indigènes en quête d'une
vie meilleure ne sont pas les seuls à
profiter de la porosité de la frontière
à 50 kilomètres en amont du fleuve dans
la région de camopi des gendarmes
français tentent d'enrayer leur paillage
clandestins la plupart des chercheurs
d'or viennent du brésil voisin
le cam au pied il y avait des traces de
passages de partout des arbres
tronçonnés en plein milieu des criques
compaq ont passablement
14 gendarmes tentent de lutter contre
ces opérations illégales autour de
camopi
des patrouilles se met d'embûches dans
une nature danse propice aux activités
clandestines
à terre l'équipe découvre des traces
récente d'orpailleurs
tout indique qu'ils viennent de lever le
camp
après quelques minutes de recherche
un orpailleur est interpellé n'a pas de
papiers
d'identité
je comprends pas une photo qui va vers
des papiers non élu on va le déposer en
fait ce qu'on lui dit il n'a pas l'aura
de revenir mais ils s'en fichent
complètement et puis il va revenir
comme une éternelle recommencement on le
sait n'est ce pas grave au genre ils
sont pas dangereux c'est gentil
travailleur leur paille agi légale
existe depuis plus de 20 ans il est très
organisé l'homme qui vient d'être
interpellé avait pour mission de
ravitailler son équipe que tout
s'est fait sans sac à dos ce que
j'appelle des choix en fait ils omettent
là ils ont les bretelles pour les
épaules et ça ils le mettront l'eau sur
le front pour le fort thématique
précharge lourde ici c'est les ballots
de vivre qu'il faudra détruire en
arrivant et lorsque quelqu'un la
gendarmerie arrive où les fagots
n'importe qui et bien ils préviennent
les autres transporteurs ou c'est sous
les autres sont autour
probablement alertés par des guetteurs
les autres orpailleurs on tue le temps
de prendre la fuite
[Musique]
les gendarmes raccompagne le brésilien
sur son territoire sans aucune sanction
faute de moyens
et là on la frontière sur sur camopi
on a un peu moins de quinze mille
kilomètres carrés de serres contre vos
circonscriptions
près de dix mille heures pailleur serait
en activité sur le sol guyanais ces deux
dernières années seuls 99 d'entre eux
ont été condamnés par la justice
française une goutte d'eau dans l'ohio
poc
[Musique]
sur le fleuve la présence des gendarmes
n'effraie pas grand monde
à camopi non plus ce village de 1800
habitants abrite les forces de l'ordre
françaises en mission contre
l'orpaillage
[Musique]
le brigadier jean marc antoine est venu
de métropole pour un contrat de quatre
ans il habite à camopi avec sa femme et
leur bébé né à cayenne
haut débit et épate
il est des plis
croisés
le couple a dû s'adapter aux conditions
de vie locales y compris pour les soins
médicaux prodigués dans l'unique
dispensaire de camopi à pas grand chose
à se préoccuper injuste la santé du bébé
tant qu'elle va bien tout va bien quoi
donc mais revenue sur come on people
avait trois jours et depuis tout se
passe très bien au contraire si on a un
petit souci on peut venir ici nous c'est
que les dispensaires elle était ouvert
ici aussi la porosité de la frontière
est évidente
20% des patients de l'établissement sont
brésiliens
moi j'ai une pirogue le 5 mai salle a
fait arriver vers
allez midi 12h 13h je sais pas jusqu'à
quand ils consultent et
benoît quintin est infirmier au
dispensaire de camopi depuis sept ans
ça fait déjà un an que le médecin
insiste pour que vous fassiez une
opération pour retirer votre intérieur
cette phase a ressurgi à otheros
comme ça vous arrêterez de saignée dans
le village brésilien de cette patiente
juste en face de camopi il n'y a qu'une
infirmière pour 600 habitants trop peu
pour répondre aux urgences
j'ai déjà reçu un traitement de l'autre
côté
et 7 très lent alors je cherche à me
faire suivre au brésil mais le
traitement n'était plus bon la situation
s'est empirée
j'étais de plus en plus mal maintenant
je sais que le traitement le plus adapté
se trouve ici du côté français
au revoir au revoir que dieu te protège
malgré la fermeture officielle de la
frontière pour lutter contre la pandémie
le dispensaire continue de tourner à
plein régime
à camopi le brigadier jean marc antoine
et ses collègues ont appris à
s'accommoder des incessants allers
retours des pirogues
le but recherché par les personnes qui
traversent la frontière c'est pas de
s'installer en france pour avoir des
papiers ou que sais-je encore c'est pas
du tout ça c'est juste de travailler
parce que ça s'est toujours fait c'est
inscrit dans les traditions très dur on
va dire ça nous on explique que la
frontière mais pourquoi on va pas
arrêter les gens parce qu'ils ont
traversé la frontière
tout le long de l'oyapock les
populations locales jouent au chat et à
la souris avec les forces de l'ordre à
saint georges orly et sa mère par te
faire leurs courses côté brésilien le
piroguier qui va les faire traverser ne
semble pas vraiment inquiet de
l'illégalité de ses activités c'est à
partir de 14 heures en général les
patrouilles sur le fleuve jusqu'à 17
heures
c'est la police aux frontières contre le
matin entre 10h et 12h et l'après midi
ce sont les gendarmes
à cette heure ci c'est tranquille
dix minutes et 8 euros c'est tout ce
qu'il faut pour passer de la france au
brésil
le prix de la traversée a doublé depuis
que la frontière est officiellement
fermée mais les familles de saint
georges sont à 40 % originaire du brésil
comme orly elle continue donc de
traverser régulièrement pour voir leurs
proches ou faire des achats
[Musique]
le produit il n'écoute de 59 reyel est
par contre à ces gens un produit comme
si ça coûte 2 3 euros
on peut passer tout ça s'arrangera avec
50 euros de sa fille sont 40 real
bon voilà donc le prix à 140 real c'est
à peu près 25 euros 30 euros
entre la guyane et le brésil le yap kok
reste une zone des changes plus qu'une
ligne de démarcation et la pandémie de
co vide qui aurait supposé une fermeture
hermétique de la frontière n'a fait que
démontrer de façon plus évidente encore
son caractère incontrôlable
hahaha
et voilà pour cette frontière sur le yap
kok entre la france et le brésil
reportage signé fanilo terre et laura
damase la semaine prochaine nous
poursuivrons cette série en nous rendant
au milieu du lac victoria le plus grand
lac d'afrique le tracé de la frontière
entre le kenya et l'ouganda y est
contestée en raison des droits de pêche
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission et à
la semaine prochaine sur france
[Musique]